what's going on guys today we're going
to theorize how things would have
changed if ever inherited the colossal
during season three of attack on titan
as we all know levi's choice to give
this shifter to armin was a big surprise
even to the freaking people who wanted
it to happen and in evan's absence hanji
became the newest leader of the survey
corps
over the following years they did learn
a lot about the outside world but failed
to take significant steps when it came
to protecting the island frustrating
aaron so much that he met elena in
secret infiltrating marley without
permission and then started a civil war
when he returned to paradise in my
opinion many of those things wouldn't
have happened if evan survived because
he usually had a solid plan for any
situation meaning if he was alive he
could have found an alternate path for
survival that no one thought of in the
main show
this video is part one of a new series
that will examine this alternate reality
but before we get into it i'm giving
away one thunk of the commander himself
and all you have to do to enter is
simply sub to the channel and leave a
comment below the winner will be chosen
at random using comicpicker.com and
we'll be announced during part two of
this series next month but remember you
have to be subbed if you want your
comment to have a chance
okay so the best place to start this
video off is when levi was about to give
evan the injection because the syringe
was literally in his arm and
realistically speaking all leave i had
to do was push down
in the original timeline the captain
paused at this moment as he briefly
thought about army's dream to reach the
sea but more importantly he also thought
about the wise words of his favorite
uncle
according to kenny ackerman all humans
need something to chase after or else
there'd be no reason to keep on living
and for evan his motivation was to
avenge his father's death by uncovering
the truth about the world earlier he'd
mentioned how this was more important
him than the survival of humanity but as
the commander of the survey corps he was
backed into a corner where he really had
to give up on his dream to defeat the
beast titan he knew the scouts wouldn't
charge at zeke unless he was leading
them and it was nice to levi's harsh
words that evan accepted it was time for
his dream to die
this acceptance of his dream being over
is a major factor in why the captain
decided not to bring him back but in
this alternate timeline that obviously
can't happen for argument's sake let's
just say levi no longer hesitates at the
crucial moment and turns the commander
into a pure titan straight away like he
intended
following that transformation everyone
will wake up many hours later having
eaten bertolt and the first thing he
noticed is the brand new right arm that
would have grown while he was asleep
this arm was bitten off by a random
titan in season two but with it
returning he would instantly realize
that he's now become a titan shifter as
with most people who gain these
abilities the commander would have no
memory of the event surrounding it so
for all he knows he could be the new
beast item the new armor titan or even
the new cart titan he genuinely just had
no idea
levi would likely be the one to update
him on everything that happened and once
that's explained they'd set out to find
the jaeger family basement with mikasa
and aaron leading the way while i think
aaron would be a complete mess thanks to
arman's death back in trust mikasa did
show composure when it comes to this
kind of thing so i feel like she'd be
able to calm him down and refocus him on
the task at hand obviously you could
argue that she wasn't that composed a
few hours earlier but with armin now
actually being gone i feel like she'd
accept there's nothing they can do to
bring him back
after searching the basement long enough
they'd eventually find the three hidden
notebooks left behind by graciaga and
this discovery would be the culmination
of evan's dream as he said he had to be
there when they learn the truth about
the world and now having learned that
truth he'd realize that enemy is a
massive nation that wants to steal the
founding titan because mali failed in
their mission everyone know they will
return at some point to try and capture
eren so strengthening the island's
defenses becomes his new top priority
over the course of the next few days
nardoc would apologize to evan for never
taking his theory seriously when they
were younger while separately eren and
mikasa would still be made to survey
short jail centers for trying to give
armin the injection the time would then
come for the leaders of parodies to
decide what they should do with grisha's
notebooks and of course this is a
perfect opportunity for evan to give one
of his classy speeches something about
how the truth needs to be made public or
else all those deaths would be for
nothing
just like in the original timeline it's
likely that during this meeting and
would realize how to access the founders
power but aaron being aaron he'd stay
quiet because he wouldn't want to risk
his story being turned into a titan
especially now that he's already lost
one of his closest friends
anyway the contents of grisha's
notebooks would then be released in the
newspaper a day later revealing the
truth about the world to the people of
the island the release of this
information would also serve a secondary
purpose for the commander as he would be
starting a recruitment drive to rebuild
the survey corps to numbers never seen
before when you combine high public
morale with the charisma of leader like
aravind thousands of regular civilians
could be convinced to become new
recruits while hundreds of existing
soldiers would defect to join the scouts
nile in particular is someone who i
think would leave the mps to join the
survey called ranks as after everything
that went down i think he'd want to
follow his old friend for whatever's
about to happen
in the months after this evan would
spend time revamping what the cervical
are about slowly turning them into an
army that's more prepared to fight back
against an invasion all the soldiers who
recently joined from other military
branches would now be trained to use
thunderspears while the fresh recruits
would mainly focus on how to kill humans
and titan shifters this type of
evolution is a logical set that i think
everyone would take as in the past he
mentioned how he viewed the scouts as a
spear made to eliminate threats given
that marley's biggest threat comes from
their shifters and the humans who might
be helping them it only makes sense that
the scouts would need to move on from
their old ways of thinking
while all of this training is going on
the executioner from hell would be
systematically wiping out most beer
titans on parodies and by the winter
99.9 of them would be gone
fast forward to the spring and the
scouts would conduct their first
expedition to the sea with the commander
planning to construct a military base
where the malian wall currently stands
he'd know that when mali returns they'll
likely come to this location given that
you know they made it themselves so the
idea would be for the base to be
fortified with weapons and have at least
one titan shifter present at all times
later that same year while the base is
under construction marley would send
their first feed of service ships to
inspect the island and on board would be
elena on yankpon and a very suspect
amount of malian wine
in the main show the arrival of zeke's
anti-malian volunteers caused a serious
debate with certain people believing
they should all be executed while others
like kanji believing that the volunteers
could be useful
when it comes to irvine i think he'd
initially be somewhere in the middle
cause on the one hand after seeing what
zeke did to the scouts there's no way
he'd believe the beast titan suddenly
wants to help the same people he killed
the commander would probably think that
the volunteers are part of some kind of
trick to steal the finding titan a
sentiment that was shared by zachary as
well
on the other hand evan would also
realize that these guys can provide
technology and knowledge that they can't
get anywhere else so it could be a
mistake to not use that to their
advantage
for that reason i think that working
carefully with the volunteers is a
gamble the commander would be willing to
make because the benefits will outweigh
the costs as long as they can keep the
founding titan safe
now for those of you that maybe forgot
when elena arrived she instantly
revealed a lot of important information
about mali including the size and
structure of their army the type of
weapons they use and the development of
their airships on top of that one of the
more interesting things she says that
often gets overlooked was that mali
couldn't invade parodies at this time
largely because they were involved in a
completely different war after losing
the female and colossal titans they were
perceived as weak by other countries
and so mali's many enemies gathered
together to try and take them out
in the original timeline this was
mentioned once by elena and never spoken
of by hanji again but for someone like
irvin he'd see the war as a chance to
crush their biggest enemy
he said himself that his goal after
reaching the basement would be to
eliminate threats on the other side of
the walls and with the right strategy
the mideast war provided a perfect
battleground to wipe out mali and
potentially make allies at the same time
hear me out on that one while it's true
the entire world seriously hates
parodies based on everything we know you
could argue that mali military is almost
equally as hated for a hundred years
they used time shifters to dominate the
planet invading countless countries
along the way and forcing civilians like
onyankapon to join their army many of
those victories were only possible
thanks to the titans so it's fair to say
that if the warriors could somehow be
eliminated then mali would very probably
lose the mideast war
in the main series we saw how the
mideast alliance was beaten thanks to
the beast and armored titans but in this
ultimate timeline irving's new strategy
could destroy the warrior unit before
this even happens
in doing that they could change how
millions of people around the world
perceive parodies and while it wouldn't
magically stop prejudice against eldians
at the very least it could allow the
island to make allies with the middle
east
obviously there are a lot of steps that
need to happen for this to be a
possibility because for a start it would
take some serious convincing for the
alliance to put aside their prejudice
and accept help from the scouts i know
some of you watching might even think
it's just impossible for that to happen
but when it comes to war certain
countries are willing to win by whatever
means necessary mali itself is perhaps
the perfect example of that because they
were oppressed for 2 000 years by the
titans yeah as soon as the opportunity
presented itself they didn't hesitate to
take seven titan shifters and use them
for themselves it's fair to say the
middle eastern alliance would likely be
no different all it takes is for someone
to convince them that they can't beat
mali without assistance from the titans
of parodies
more details about this potential team
up will be shown in part 2 but for now
let's move over to what would happen in
the month after the volunteers arrive
to start with aaron would reveal the
secret he's been hiding about how to
activate the founding titan and in this
moment the possibility of a rumbling
becomes known to everyone in the room
in my opinion the commander would treat
the rumbling as a backup option in case
they were like being bombarded or
something but no way would it be his
number one choice cause i mean first of
all a full-scale rumbling was never
anyone's first option and even a partial
use of the rumbling would only make
parodies a bigger target to those who
survive
if ervin's idea to join the mideast war
is going to happen they need to avoid
making new enemies by doing a rumbling
and instead focus on diplomacy starting
with asia and the middle east by
establishing peace agreements with those
other nations it could be the start of a
relationship that in the long term can
turn parodies into a modern country that
doesn't need titans to survive
in the year 842 history would then make
their initial visit to the island and at
the time of their arrival the midi sword
would still be raging on this meeting
would be important for a number of
reasons but above everything else it's a
chance for evan to persuade kyomi to
abandon zeke's proposal and follow his
idea instead
as we all know zeke's plan required erin
to activate a small-scale rumbling to
scare off other nations for the next 50
years and in that time history would
then help build parodies into a modern
country
the big downside was that historia and
her descendants would have to inherit
the beast titan so that they always had
a titan of royal blood and could
therefore always do the rumbling the
problem is that this is something aaron
was desperate to avoid and i think with
armin having died in this new timeline
he'd be even more determined to make
sure the rest of his friends can live
long lives because of this aaron would
100 be against zeke's rumbling idea and
will put his faith in the commander
instead who you know his plan by
contrast doesn't require a titan of
royal blood but what it does need is
cooperation from other countries
starting with the asian clan
history's resources would enable the
scouts to infiltrate mali at which point
they can split into teams and steal the
draw armoured cart and possibly the
beast tyson whether they take the beast
titan will depend on certain factors
that will be discussed in the next video
but the main point is that by launching
a surprise attack on the warrior unit
mali will be weakened to a point where
they can potentially be destroyed
it should be said though that if kyomi
was to assist the scouts in this
alternate plan it would be a massive
betrayal of zeke's trust since if
they're not going to do a rumbling then
there's no reason why paradise would
bring him to meet his brother that being
said zeke's troubles aren't really
kyomi's problem as the anime showed us
she's capable of betraying people or
lying to their face if it serves her
best interests
given that her country's been on the
decline ever since the great titan war i
generally feel like she could be
persuaded by irvine to go along with his
plan as long as it still involves her
getting access to the iceberg stone
reserves the ice burst stone is a
special fuel source found only on
parodies and according to hyomi it's so
valuable that it could return our nation
to its former glory so she be desperate
to reach a deal with the aldians even if
it's not the one she originally planned
in return for access to the iceberg
stone hizuru can provide the scouts with
travel to mali and the middle east as
well as passing on the tools needed to
build the island into a more civilized
society the way i see it both sides of
something the other once so for that
reason kiyomi and erin should be able to
reach an agreement that doesn't involve
the rumbling and yeah you'll see how
that develops in part two
before i end this one there were two
things i didn't get the chance to talk
about yet the first being whether
berto's memories would be affecting the
commander in any way in the main
timeline we saw how berto's influence
made armin fall in love with a crystal
but for the commander i personally don't
think that would happen unlike armin he
had no pre-existing relationship with
either bertolt or annie and you know
that was clearly a factor in why armin
was being haunted from the very
beginning
most of the time the memories of a
predecessor don't majorly affect the
next person anyway as you've seen with
yamir reiner and even berto himself they
were all unaffected by the previous
person i think everyone would likely be
in that same group but let me know what
you think in the comments down below
the second thing i didn't get to mention
were the events surrounding this
ceremony as in the original series erin
kisses storia's hand causing him to see
memories from different points in time
this kiss would still happen in the
alternate reality where evan survived
although the visions aaron sees now
would not be exactly the same i imagine
he'd still pull the same face though
because there are a few ways in which
this timeline is actually much worse
than the original one but we'll get to
that in future parts
if you enjoyed this video then be sure
to smash that sub button if you haven't
already and until the next one peace out